you mentioned that you are a germaphobe
yeah and famously a germaphobe you
fist-bump your yeah
how do you handle the flu and being
around your family during flu season
what do you do do you just go into a
bubble no I won't go I won't even go to
the doctor I'll do that you know what I
do Web MD I do that I take care of
everything
maybe I shouldn't plug I don't know if
it's uh I do everything but not
everything you know what on WebMD do you
ever look up stuff they're like I get to
look up short attention span because I'm
trying to think of how to put this I
wanted it because I know that prostate
health is important and I did it myself
because I looked it up online you got
your own prostate yes what did you don't
check yours
no but they don't tell you that you
should clip your nails they don't tell
you that online monster I age you would
have to they're making fun of it you
have to check your prostate yes I've
gone and had my prostate checked but it
doesn't because I don't trust their
because they do that they'll put their
finger in there and they'll say it's
enlarged how do they you know it's
enlarged and it's not just a new doctor
with a shorter finger this way that's a
good point you can keep track so you're
telling people they should check their
own prostate no I'm saying I will if you
give me my phone back
you